When building an app that uses
location services like this,
there are a number of events that
happen in the app lifecycle,
in addition to the usual
activity lifecycle events.
Let's take a look at the entire
set of events, one by one, and
specify what we need to do in each.
First of course, is the OnCreate method.
We've implemented this already.
This is called when our
activity is created.
In this we set up the GoogleApiClient.
And we tell it to use
location services and
the location of the call backs to call
when stuff happens on the client.
Once OnCreate has done its thing
the app will start running.
And because we're using asynchronous
callbacks on the GoogleApiClient
more functions are going to fire
while the client is running.
So immediately after OnCreate Android
calls the OnStart activity.
And in this we will tell
the GoogleApiClient
again to start connecting
to location services.
Depending on the relationship
between the client and
the location services,
one of three things will happen.
If it connects successfully
the OnConnected callback will fire.
We'll look at this in a moment.
If it fails,
the OnConnectionFailed will fire.
If it was previously connected, but
something has gone wrong with
the connection causing it to suspend,
then the OnConnectionSuspended
will fire.
You need to implement all three of these
functions or your app won't compile.
So be sure at the very least to put a
logging line in the ones that you don't
want to write detailed code for yet,
for example the OnConnectionFailed and
the OnConnectionSuspended.
Now let's look at OnConnected.
In this method, we'll create
a new LocationRequest object.
We'll set its priority,
we'll set its interval, and
then we'll start requesting
updates from Location Services.
We'll see what that code
looks like in a moment.
Now when the Location Services see
a new location for the device,
they will then give a callback
to OnLocationChanged, and
this will give you a location object.
This object, you can parse with
details about the location,
such as the latitude and longitude.